pues como dicen en todo el mundo ahorita
es un momento de vergüenza para que los
norteamericanos los americanos que
tenemos una historia una historia de
democracia más de 250 años 250 años que
no hemos tenido cambio de 91
otros sin violencia esta es la primera
vez que hemos vivido este presidente de
trap que se ha revelado con un dictador
george washington fue un presidente de
nuestro primer presidente pero fue un
presidente bueno porque él
voluntariamente dejó la presidencia este
presidente trap no se quiere ir de la
presencia sabe que él perdió y ahora en
el capitolio estábamos recibiendo los
votos del pueblo para asegurar que salía
el nuevo presidente para expresar en
bailén
debo decir que este presidente trap es
responsable por la violencia que ha
ocurrido en los eeuu una cosa fea o una
cosa sucia y le voy a decir los policías
del capitolio están muy bien armados muy
bien armados y si ellos quisieran
balancear a la gente hubiera visto
muchos muertos pero estaban respetando
el derecho de estas personas a andar de
protesta pero nunca se imaginaban que
iba a pasar esto y ahorita estamos muy
enojados
estamos muy avergonzados por el que lo
que ha pasado los eeuu pero lo voy a
decir de esta situación como dice el
dicho no hay un mal que salga un bien y
cuando yo estaba en esa cámara de
congreso
que estaban los policías sacando las
armas preparando para balancear los que
pasaban en sobre esas puertas
los demócratas y los republicanos
colegas nos unimos a ayudar a esos con
representantes de tercera edad moverse a
las señoritas que se movieran que se
evacuarán hicimos algo muy bonito y
todos estábamos preparados para defender
esa área y para mí va a salir este país
más unido porque ya hemos reconocido que
este presidente trump no es nada más que
un dictador que no se quiere ir pero
marc en mi las palabras yo luis correa
no salgo de washington dice hasta que
tengamos un nuevo presidente hasta que
el congreso acabe su trabajo de
certificar las elecciones y tener un
nuevo presidente señor correa cuenta y
nos quisiéramos saber de primera mano el
testimonio de alguien que estuvo allí
presente cuando comenzaron los
disturbios cuando comenzaron a llegar al
capitolio los manifestantes apoyando a
donald trump cómo fue que no empezaron a
vivir los primeros momentos y cómo se
desarrollo
pues mira estábamos allí el debate
aceptando los votos de arizona comenzó
los colegas republicanos protestando los
demócratas un debate como debe de ser en
una democracia
vamos a platicar vamos a gritar
bajo los derechos que nos da la
constitución y de repente que veo los
policías corriendo para la cámara de
diputados- sacando a nancy pelosi
sacando al líder liderazgo republicano y
demócrata y diciendo algo está pasando
prepárense y de repente subieron truenos
no sabemos que si eran balazos o eran
bombas de gas y de repente entraron más
guardas diciendo si alguien entra aquí
se ven bombas de explosión de gas
pónganse una máscara de gas y luego
decir yo no tengo una máscara de gas
pero me sorprendieron porque los
guardias me dijeron debajo de los que
están sentados allí hay más claras
llegadas entonces estos señores ya
sabían que posiblemente iba a pasar algo
no sabíamos nosotros pero ellos
anticiparon
y ese momento que se empecé a oír mucho
ruido
cerraron las puertas a las cámaras de
diputados y de repente los guardias
levantaron
a pedazos
ideas
cosas muy antiguas y las aventaron las
las puertas para asegurar que no podían
haber abrir los protestantes las puertas
armas sacadas y todos ahí preparados
para defender a esa cámara
cuenteros donde se encuentra usted ahora
está resguardado en qué situación está
mire yo no quiero salir de washington yo
todavía estoy en el capitolio y yo no
quiero salir de washington hasta que
acabemos nuestro trabajo de certificar
el voto del pueblo este presidente este
dictador este sinvergüenza no nos va a
ganar y no vamos a tener miedo vamos a
acabar nuestro trabajo y va a seguir
adelante la democracia de los eeuu no
vamos a dejar que nos roben nuestro país
que nos robe nuestra democracia
cuéntenos el señor correa en qué lugar
exacto se encuentra usted del capitolio
y cómo van a continuar ahora esta
jornada tiene esa información oficial se
suspende de manera oficial o todavía de
reina la incertidumbre respecto del
futuro de estación al día hay
incertidumbre porque como usted sabe
invadieron estas personas muchas áreas
del capitolio se teme que posiblemente
hayan puesto bombas hayan puesto cosas
negativas en el capitolio si es que
vamos a esperar a evacuar chequear todo
y vamos a empezar o posiblemente nos
podemos mover a otro sitio para seguir
nuestro trabajo como congresistas han
recibido algunas órdenes hagamos
recibidor y está estamos esperando
estamos entonces de manera que están
permaneciendo algunos en sus oficinas
otros en pasillos etcétera viendo cómo
se desarrolla la situación muchos siguen
en el capitolio y usted que considera
que será lo más probable que pueda
llegará a suceder una suspensión una
reprogramación por supuesto lo
fundamental es guardar salvaguardarnos
la integridad física de todos los
funcionarios exactamente y asegurar que
siga adelante el proceso democrático
democrático no podemos dejar que este
dictador siga adelante ya hemos dado a
nuestra palabra como votantes hemos
elegido a bailén como nuestro próximo
presidente y no vamos a respirar no
vamos a dejar no vamos a descansar hasta
que él salga como presidente ahora señor
corría
las declaraciones de donald trump y del
vicepresidente saliente mike pence
contrastan de alguna manera no donald
trump hizo un llamado a que regresen a
sus hogares pidió ley orden volvió a
reiterar que les robaron las elecciones
no obstante el vicepresidente saliente
mike pence fue quizás un poco más duro
con las personas que llegaron hasta el
capitolio dijo que se les aplicaría
y les quedaría todo con todo el peso de
la ley' mejor dicho considera usted que
hay matices entre presidente de donald
trump y la gestión de este conflicto con
respecto del viernes antes de que
empezará hoy el proceso de ser
certificación de aceptar los votos del
pueblo
presidente de trump estaba echándole la
culpa pero es señor tiene el poder de
parar el rojo que me han robado la
presidencia y pensó tiene ese poder así
sé que ya sabiendo que el presidente lo
estaba echando a mike pence adelante lo
estaba echando como dice no tirándolo a
la calle
este presidente no le importa a quien le
va a causar daño a los republicanos ya
los demócratas y le voy sir hay muchos
republicanos que estaban resistiendo las
acciones del presidente y esas personas
son héroes porque esas personas se
lanzaron contra su propio presidente
diciéndole que no le iban a tolerar sus
tonterías
ahora como congresista demócrata y
teniendo en cuenta esta suerte de
detenciones no al interior del partido
republicano sobre todo entre donald
trump y figuras líderes de su partido
considera usted que existe la
posibilidad y también teniendo en cuenta
no esta suerte de trómpiz mo que muchos
consideran como un nuevo movimiento
incluso a la derecha de los republicanos
considera usted que a partir del próximo
mandato de joe biden podría haber
una mayor cómo decirlo un mayor diálogo
mayor acercamiento entre demócratas y
republicanos
para mí uno de los positivos que va a
salir de estas situaciones que nos va a
unir yo presiento que los demócratas
como republicanos vamos a unirnos a
reconocer los problemas de este país
para tratar de traer un alivio a esta
patria que no sigamos tan divididos
señor correa cuál es su pronóstico por
llamarlo de alguna manera de lo que
pueda llegar a suceder no sé si tiene
algún antecedente de este tipo en la
política estadounidense en el creo que
por lo que hemos hablado con analistas
han sido muy pocos tenido en cuenta este
antecedente que se vio hoy no en el
capitolio estadounidense que quiere que
pueda llegar a suceder de acá a un
futuro no con la nominación de bardem
bueno con la declaración y confirmación
de joe biden y la gobernabilidad en el
país
nunca ha pasado tal cosa en los eeuu
nunca ha pasado una cosa en esta gran
democracia nunca ha habido tan una
situación también corts vergonzosa para
los eeuu ahorita los únicos las únicas
personas que les están dando risa van a
ser los el dictador chino el dictador
ruso y a todos nuestros enemigos eso es
una cosa un desastre a los eeuu pero
hemos aprendido que la democracia es
algo delicado es algo que se tiene que
trabajar para asegurar que tengamos una
democracia
aprovechando bueno que estamos hablando
con un congresista al interior del
congreso estadounidense en este contexto
de tantas tensiones que se están
viviendo así quisiera pedirle a usted
qué mensaje tiene para los
estadounidenses y para el resto de la
comunidad internacional no en este
contexto tan particular
que no nos pierdan confianza seguimos
siendo una democracia los eeuu de
américa
vamos a seguir luchando para asegurar
que vamos que tengamos un nuevo
presidente en menos de tres semanas y
esta democracia va a seguir adelante
tengamos confianza pero al mismo tiempo
esta es una lección no nomás para los
eeuu sino para todo el mundo como yo le
he dicho la democracia no es algo
automática tenemos que cuidarla y como
votantes tenemos que articular la
información que tenemos no sea
propaganda muchas gracias
gracias a usted señor correa por estos
minutos en france 24